There is a new sort of enlightened centrist
hot take, which is OK. Biden's doing well on
vaccinations now, but it's all built on the system
that Donald Trump and his administration built,
and that couldn't be further from the truth.
There is a good article in Talking Points Memo
by Kate Rega and Josh Kavinsky, which says,
you know, The Washington Post is doing this,
The New York Times is doing this. They're
saying that the speed up we are seeing now
builds on the Trump plan and it is simply wrong.
Kate and Josh do a deep dove into what was
actually happening in the Trump administration
during the last few months. And in fact,
it's stunning at how well Joe Biden has been able
to expand vaccination. Despite Donald Trump's
actions, there was no plan left behind. Biden
and his team had to build the plan from day one
for how to get the vaccines once they were dumped.
It states to places that are actually vaccinating
established vaccination sites and the like
there even when given the opportunity on supply,
Joe Biden has had to fix the problems that
Donald Trump left behind, including Trump
famously turning down one hundred million doses
of Pfizer back in July of twenty twenty, maybe
because Pfizer wasn't participating in Operation
Warp Speed. That left Joe Biden to figure out
how can we actually get enough vaccines for
people and now we will have enough vaccines
were on May 1st. We will be opening eligibility
to everybody. Eighteen plus in the United States,
every aspect of what Donald Trump did was
counterproductive other than what we could
say here is the praise we could give of Donald
Trump. Beyond all the things he did to stifle
us having enough vaccines and reduce interest in
vaccination, Trump didn't actively deny funding.
To companies developing vaccines, and that's
barely praise, and I know that one of the
things you heard, there were two things that
were repeatedly mentioned during the Trump era
that Trump was doing. One is he's funding
vaccine research. Just about every country
was funding vaccine research in the middle of a
global pandemic. What government wouldn't fund
research to some degree to say that Trump deserves
praise for that? If he didn't do it, it would have
been criminal. Now, many of the companies
researching vaccines didn't take the money
or they didn't need the money. But to say Trump
funded stuff, I mean, listen to government funds,
endless things, and to say that's why he gets
credit is very low. Now, the other thing is,
you know, Trump tells the story of how they came
to me. They said, sir, let's fund manufacture
of vaccines even before we know these vaccines
are going to be effective. And the ones to use
this has been widely done across the world for
decades. When you have an urgent situation and
you have a vaccine or a medication that looks
like it will work, but it's still being tested.
You don't want to waste time. You want doses ready
to go if and when it gets approved. So what you do
is you manufacture vaccines on spec. You start
manufacturing a bunch of different candidates so
that if they get approved, you already have some
doses. Trump did fund that. I guess he gets credit
for that. Now, what about on the other side, what
did he do to hurt the vaccine effort? Well, number
one, when you say it's not serious for a year
and that it's being exaggerated by the left and
that all aspects of this start to take away your
freedom and all of the stuff that reduces people's
interest in getting vaccinated, because why would
I get vaccinated for something, my dear leader,
Trump has been telling me isn't serious for a
year. No to Trump's own vaccination happened
while he was still in office in secret. And we
only learned about it in the last week or so
because it leaked. That is not something you do
if you're trying to get more people interested in
getting the vaccine. Number three, Trump declined
doses when they were offered by Pfizer in July of
twenty twenty. As I mentioned, again, maybe mad
because they weren't part of Operation Warp Speed.
And it left us with a need for Joe Biden
to figure out where to get more doses. So
I'm sorry, guys. Trump doesn't deserve credit
for vaccines. Trump was to some degree.
Just not a factor in that he allowed money to go
towards some vaccine research and did some things
that decreased interest in the vaccine and hand it
off, no plan to Joe Biden. He he could have more
aggressively hurt the cause. But Trump doesn't
deserve credit for these vaccines. And what we
are seeing now in terms of the rollout and the
expansion was a plan that Joe Biden started
building in December, knowing what he was coming
into. And Joe Biden has not. Joe Biden. There's
lots of things he doesn't deserve praise
for right now which have criticized him for.
This is Joe Biden's thing. He put in place a
parallel coronavirus task force back in December.
They started figuring this out. When they took
over, there was no plan. They built the plan.
They secured doses from a JMJ They got additional
doses lined up from Edirne, up from Pfizer. This
really is Biden's thing. And it seems pretty clear
that voters realize that. But for some reason,
Dr. Anthony Fauci is baffled by what's going
on. And I want to talk about that next.